when you wake up generally what the
research shows is that your brain is
primed to be able to focus for the first
four hours of the day the first four
hours of the day tend to be for most of
us the time of day when your brain has
the most fuel and when your speed of
processing is awesome and when you are
able to direct your attention at what
you need there's a caveat to this you
can manufacture boosts of productivity
and boosts of feeling like you've got a
little bit more brain power number one
immediately after you exercise so if you
have a burst of cardio 30 minutes is
what a lot of the research says but if
you have a burst of cardio you will get
a little bit of increase in fuel but
generally speaking everybody you need to
start to marry mornings with Peak
productivity if you can own your
mornings if you you can put that thing
that matters to you first thing in the
morning and make a little bit of
progress on it you are going to start to
feel like you are more in control you're
going to start to see yourself using
your best brain power and your highest
level of fuel at the thing that matters
most to you need motivation you better
watch a top ten with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carl Michael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Mel Robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two dream with the lid off
give yourself permission
to dream with the lid off this is really
important and the reason why this is
important is because I guarantee you
that right now you are not even allowing
yourself to fully dream or think about
or set goals that are truly aligned with
what you deeply want in your heart that
you aren't even able to manifest
properly because you're not even honest
with yourself about what you actually
want this is a really common thing
because you're allowing your self-doubt
you are allowing your fears your anxiety
your insecurity you're allowing where
you are to dictate and limit where you
want to go and so step one super
important you must allow yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system I write about the RAS
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit the
RAS is a filter in your mind and you can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do in
order to teach yourself how to dream
with the lid off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliberate action and you write
down what you want you are signaling to
your brain that you deserve to have
these things you're signaling to your
brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off so that's step number one you're
going to start writing down five things
that you want every single morning as a
way to train your mind to let you dream
freely rule number three visualize the
reason why visualization and picturing
yourself succeeding and allowing
yourself to feel the happiness and the
pride that comes with picturing a
positive future the reason why that's as
important is let's say Shelley does that
every single day this week every day she
wakes up she walks for five minutes and
as she's walking on that treadmill she's
visualizing herself finishing a 10K in
six months and how proud she is every
time she does that she is changing
what's going on up here
this isn't something I made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if Shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning and
instead of thinking about the worst case
instead of looking at your body in the
mirror and going I'm so fat I'm so out
of shape I'll never run a 10K it's never
going to happen why didn't I exercise
last year I hate my flabby stomach I
hate my my big thighs I hate how out of
shape I'm embarrassed like if that's
what you're thinking
then that is what you're allowing your
brain to continue to filter the world
through
if you start teaching yourself the skill
of visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K
if after an entire week what Shelley
does is she looks in the mirror and she
goes I'm getting stronger every day I'm
really proud of myself even though I'm
I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying you're
flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10K
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just seven to
ten days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm gonna say I'm proud I'm doing
this why don't you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why I'm so glad you're doing it rule
number four identify important things
when I hear the word productivity
I don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list
because part of the reason why you don't
feel productive is because you're busy
doing the things that aren't important
to you yeah do you need to make sure you
have milk or you got almond milk or oat
milk in the fridge of course you do but
have you ever notice that all the busy
crap in life uh tends to take care of
itself that you don't really need to
focus your time and energy on the
minutia that's on your to-do list
because that stuff tends to grab your
attention what you really need to do is
figure out how to create time and how to
create the focus that you need in order
to feel like you are making progress on
the important things
and that's really what productivity
means to me you get all kinds of stuff
done you're really busy in your life
aren't you but are you getting progress
made on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan you need to have a very
short list every week of what actually
matters to you okay because I guarantee
you if you were to do an audit of the
way that you spend your time this week
you would probably see that 95 of your
time is spin on things that you really
don't care about
and even more scary I bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
TV on also answering emails that is the
least productive way to spend your time
multitasking spending your time just
sort of zoning out on things that don't
matter what I want you to do is I want
you right now to think about what is it
between now and the end of this week for
example what is it that matters to you
what's the most important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay it's a whole other conversation for
us to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you what
you do not have right now is you do not
have a plan for
prioritizing the important stuff in your
life also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design designed
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five set boundaries if you
struggle with boundaries I want you to
know you're not alone and this is super
common and
um one of the reasons why I'm excited to
share everything that I've learned about
boundaries with you is because I used to
be the kind of person that had zero
boundaries I mean not a nothing zilch
nothing in fact there were periods of my
life where it was worse than zero
because I was so attached in romantic
relationships that I literally would
become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally if it's possible to have
negative boundaries meaning you like
somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as a emotionally
attached in relationships and as people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify communicate and uphold
boundaries in my life you can learn how
to do this too okay and so that's what
we're going to unpack in this video
so I think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why we don't have good
boundaries is because none of us were
trained how to set them I mean I want
you to think about your childhood for a
minute your childhood with your
caregivers your parents or grandparents
whoever it is naturally an imbalance
right like when you come into this world
you are born into a particular family
you're born into a particular culture
religion economic situation a place in
the world a race like a religion and
based on where you were born and to whom
you were born into in terms of the
family structure there were all kinds of
rules that you had to follow and if you
did not follow those rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine if you as like an eight-year-old
started to try to express boundaries
literally like mom cooks a uh you know a
pot pot roast dinner and you cross your
arms you're like you know Mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom would probably go guess
what youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
Crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so saying boundaries
when you're little doesn't really work
for the adults in your life and that's
why you never learned how to do it and
by the way your parents were probably
never taught how to have boundaries
either and so
I want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin where do you
even begin when it comes to learning how
to set healthy boundaries okay
so first things first where you're going
to begin is you're going to start to
think about boundaries in a completely
new way okay the number one mistake that
we all make I made it you're making it
right now is when you think about
boundaries you are thinking about other
people first okay you're thinking about
boundaries uh and believing that your
boundaries are rules in a relationship
that define respect and that somehow
your boundaries are going to control or
change someone else's Behavior that is
the exact opposite of how you should be
thinking about boundaries okay and I'm
going to give you a bunch of examples
don't worry I didn't realize this this
is why I was lousy at setting boundaries
because I thought that my boundaries
control what other people do no no no no
no no so how do I want you to think
about boundaries okay
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
yep I'm gonna say that again boundaries
are rules that you create
about your own behavior rule number six
reframe negative patterns understand
you will always find people to criticize
you watch though how when somebody
outside of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking that gets triggered that
disempowers you
that I won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath I won't have the
words
yeah they won't be the right words and I
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not smart enough to make
a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that I'm stupid they're okay there we go
that's a good one not a good one but you
know what I mean that's a good one
because that's my biggest okay I'm a
piece of [ __ ]
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
so I don't I don't know who told me that
when did you start believing that
it's a little girl yeah
and I've just been saying it for so long
I I don't know that's okay she said I've
been saying it for so long I don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're going to start to connect the
dots okay and so here's the thing
at some point you started telling
yourself whatever I'm a piece as a
strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well I'm a piece of [ __ ] you actually
got really quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations when
you would have been abused or something
it worked because it protected you as
weird as it sounds yeah is that but are
you seeing something what are you seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah we couldn't make noise and okay and
if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah I didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so every time that you are
in a situation where you need to speak
up how many are you relating to this by
the way
I have a theory about all of us
that we have patterns and strategies
that we would we created when we were
little
in order to survive situations
and what she
internalize was don't speak up and
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you do
and believe me that protected your ass
it worked because you didn't speak up
and you didn't get in trouble with your
dad right and I still got the love so if
I speak up now I'm going to lose my
dad's love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got written
when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked the problem is now
that you're working now it's not working
now
it's not working now not working now and
see exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on a stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up you're yes freeze and you're gonna go
five four three two one the only thing
to that actually overrides this pattern
is to speak
and through speaking
you will see that you're not a piece of
[ __ ] you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
I guess I'm just a piece of something to
say
yes
that's right and I also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff even the heavy stuff because
it loses its grip on me it works for me
it may not work for you
but it's something to try rule number
seven manifest what you want first of
all you got to give yourself permission
to really have what you want okay
because you got to have the thing that
you're visualizing be something that is
authentically something that you want
number two you must see yourself taking
the steps the tiny actions and doing the
work that will lead you to creating or
having what you want
third you gotta feel in your body what
it feels like to do the work and you
also have to feel Pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really imprinting and training and
preparing for it and fourth uh obviously
you got to take the actions and all of
that manifesting and preparing inspires
you to take the actions but one place
where so many folks get stuck when they
start trying to make manifesting a daily
habit is you go and you know what you
want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you I'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend Mel Robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire and the
power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now I'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the Harvard Business
School review they did eight different
studies at the University of Wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay I want you to imagine
yourself asking for a raise or applying
for that dream job when you visualize
yourself doing it you immediately focus
in on minutia you start imagining all
kinds of things that could go wrong you
start arguing against yourself and doubt
comes flooding in you have a very
cautious mindset when you place yourself
in those scenarios however if you were
to visualize me Mel Robbins asking for
that race immediately your mindset
switches to being very bold being
creative seeing all kinds of
opportunities and in fact when you not
only visualize me your friend Mel
Robbins asking for that raise that you
want when you give me advice you're
super enthusiastic you're like Mel you
should go for it and I bet in your life
you have probably told friends or loved
ones you should ask for for more money
and you mean it because you're
visualizing them but you yourself
won't visualize yourself doing that you
talk yourself out of it we've all had
this experience you yourself are
probably sitting there by your right Mel
I constantly tell my friends you deserve
more you should break up with that jerk
you should go for it but when it comes
to yourself
you see the excuses in depth so I want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend Mel Robbins or insert
anybody that you love rule number eight
focus on progress part of the reason why
you don't feel productive is because
you're trying to complete everything and
so let's take one of the things that I
saw somebody write that you want to uh
clean up one of the spare rooms in your
apartment or in your house that maybe
there's a spare bedroom and you have
been wanting to turn it into a home
office or maybe one of the kids has
moved out of the house and you want to
declutter that room like in a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me our daughter moved out
and started her life uh you know post
college and our other daughter is out in
Los Angeles going into college and we no
joke
have three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it and it has been sitting
there for two months so maybe you have a
pile of that kind of stuff in your house
this is not a priority for me I'm
perfectly fine with it sitting in the
room where our laundry is the priority
for me this week is to carve out
dedicated time to hang out with our 16
year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage that could take
you two days to do it the right way
right because you know if you don't give
yourself enough time then you're gonna
piles and so then you think I can't get
it done and so then you never schedule
it right okay we're not going to worry
about completion everybody we're going
to worry about progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress it can shrink the amount of
time that you need maybe all that you're
going to do is you're going to work on
one dresser in the room or you're going
to work on one shelving unit in the
garage and by simply making the time to
number one identify what matters to you
and number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will Define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about
um what you need to do okay I literally
have notes for this oh there we go and I
just lost it because I really want to
make sure that I teach you all this
stuff so
um here Becca can you help me because
this is not oh because my thing is not
never mind guys I am I am trying
multitasking is not how you be
productive and you're watching me
multitask right now
we're going to get into some of the
science now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that I first learned
about in the Harvard Business Review so
if it's in the Harvard Business Review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from Harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
uh comes from a study where researchers
looked at I believe it was 14 000 work
journals and what they found after
looking at the work journals of how
people spent their time fourteen
thousand people is that at the end of
the week the people that felt like they
had been the most productive and the
people who felt the most fulfilled by
their work week were the people who
simply made progress on something that
mattered and so by you identifying what
matters to you this week and by you
identifying a way that you can make a
small amount of progress on it you are
leveraging This research research from
Harvard Business review of about what
creates productivity and meaning and
fulfillment in your life and that's
making progress on something that
matters number nine do the work you need
to do the work okay you got to do the
work because it's only through your
actions that you will accomplish what
you want let's say uh that you've always
wanted to climb a particular Mountain
okay there's a mountain called Haystack
it's not even that tall so I should
probably pick a bigger one but let's
just call it Haystack Mountain you've
always wanted to climb Haystack Mountain
you pull up to Haystack Mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know National Forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my God
that's a really far way away you know I
don't really know how I feel about doing
this anymore because that looks like
it's going to take a really long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go I don't think I want to
do this because I don't think I feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamed of
climbing you've now come up with an
excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it you pull the rip cord you're out
of there in order to have what you want
in life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you have stopped creating
excuses for why you can't or don't feel
like it and you must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you and then you must take the action
and start walking toward what you want
and it'll be a hell of a lot easier for
you to do that if you have also been
putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the excuses that are stopping
you now and feel proud in every fiber of
your being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly and if you do that
before you pull into the National Park
parking lot if you look up at that
mountain and you see clouds and it
starts raining it won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment and your mind body and spirit and
you my friend will start walking up that
trail
and you're going to be proud Andrew
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is be authentic so
many of us have this perfectionism Gene
and the reason why we're perfectionists
is we're trying to insulate ourselves
from criticism that if you get it
perfect no one will give you feedback if
you get it right nobody's going to
criticize you if you do it perfect then
no one will be able to attack you and
the problem with that and that's just
another side of the same coin which is
the fear of disappointing people you're
managing not disappointing people not by
lying and not by being codependent but
by actually trying to be a perfectionist
so that nobody criticizes you so let me
tell you a story about the fear of
disappointing people in my own life
because this is the biggest trigger in
my life I mean it goes back to being in
fourth grade right it's there and this
is another thing I I literally have to
remind myself of this everybody every
single day you cannot remove the things
that that trigger you you can't if
you've been doing a pattern since fourth
grade there will be things for the rest
of your life that will trigger that
pattern to come up but you can always
choose not to repeat the pattern so
you'll be triggered and be afraid that
you're going to disappoint somebody
that's real that's normal it's natural
it's part of being a human being I think
it's interwoven into every relationship
where you love somebody but you don't
have to behave the way that you always
behaved when you're nervous about
disappointing somebody so let me give
you a dumb story you ready when my
husband and I got married my father gave
us this really Incredible Gift he gave
us an antique pool table I grew up in
Muskegon Michigan where Brunswick was
founded and my dad has a hobby of going
to garage sales and estate sales and
buying old dilapidated pool tables and
then he restores them so when Chris and
I got married he bought us an old
dilapidated pool table from the same era
as our house which is the 1870s He
restored the whole thing and then
recently he and I rented a U-Haul and we
drove this sucker from Muskegon Michigan
to Boston Massachusetts my dad and I
took a road trip get there and we
assemble the pool table in what used to
be our playroom fast forward three or
four years the speaking business takes
off my business starts to grow we have
people that work for us and my kids are
older we don't need a playroom we need
an office the pool table is in the
middle of this thing for the first two
years of having the office we kept the
pool table there why because I didn't
want my dad to be disappointed because I
love him now he visits our house twice a
year for two or three days with my mom
and I kept this thing occupying a third
of our office for two years and then I
realized I'm being ridiculous I'm being
absolutely ridiculous now here's the
thing will he be disappointed if I take
the pool table down absolutely
definitely they're always going to be
things that you do decisions that you
have to make in your life in your
business for your family that will
disappoint other people it's unavoidable
but the fact that he's going to be
disappointed should never be the reason
that I don't do something that is
aligned with my values now let's take it
a step further when you make a decision
that is likely going to disappoint
people or that does still make the
decision because it's your life there's
nothing worse than when you start to Rob
your future and your life and your
happiness because you're so focused on
other people however if you love people
you can still take care of them when you
make that decision so let me go back to
the example of the pool table so I knew
I was going to take it down I knew my
father was going to be disappointed I
was disappointed I don't have a big
house so I don't you know I don't have
the room for a huge pool table I don't
have a finished basement like a lot of
people I don't have like a cool garage
game room thing like I just don't have
it I called him first and said I need to
talk to you about something you know the
pool table I love the pool table dad my
business is growing so much I actually
need an office and oh great it'll be
great in the office and I'm like well
yeah would except I have you know three
or four people showing up we got to put
some desks in there for now even went
down well you could put a piece of
plywood they could work on the pool
table and then they could do the thing
and then the thing and now my heart is
racing because I don't want to
disappoint my dad and now he's fighting
for the and I had to just say for me dad
here's what's going to happen I'm going
to hire professional movers in the pool
table business to disassemble this with
love and care we're going to store it
beautifully when I either get a
full-time office off-site or I build a
barn or I build a different house this
will have its own beautiful room
dedicated to you so we had this
beautiful conversation now was he
disappointed absolutely when they come
to the house and visit which they just
did and they walk into the office do I
feel a Pang you better believe I do it
doesn't matter that's all normal I still
need to make the decisions that I need
to make and the difference what's
changed is how I relate to that fear so
instead of what I would do in in the
past is I would make a decision that
doesn't serve me I'd leave the pool
table and then I'd be all about it I'd
leave the pool table as a way to make my
dad happy but it makes me miserable to
leave it there because I need the space
right and then I'd be kind of annoyed
and then he'd come and I'd fake play
pool because I kind of want to run you
know you know you know what I'm saying
like we do all this
that's not real and what I've been able
to do for myself in some instances when
I catch it is to hit it head on and to
be authentic and to still take care of
people and what I've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you you know
you're never going to get around this
everybody in your family is going to be
disappointed with you probably once a
day probably and you have the ability to
retrain how you respond to that trigger
that rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is make the
decision that's aligned with your values
and the thing that supports you and then
take care of the person by being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody the way we've all been handling
it myself included is manipulation lying
resentment withholding and that doesn't
serve anybody
there is no fast track to transformation
you have to work on it in little ways
every day you can't buy self-esteem or
self-love you must build it you must
stand face to face with the part of you
that you hate you must forgive yourself
for the hurt that you've caused
especially the hurt you've caused
yourself and then you got to do the work
to become a better you
it's the only way to create the
self-respect and build the self-esteem
that you want you can change there are
do-overs in life because you get one
every single morning when you wake up
look in the mirror and decide who you're
going to be today you can choose you can
change no you can't go back in time but
you can have your own back as you use
the time that you have now to take
control and create a new chapter that
makes you proud of who you are the
hardest part of all this is flipping
your focus from what you hate and are
trying to fix
toward what you want to create remember
the windshield in a car is bigger than
the rear view mirror for good reason
you're not supposed to go backwards
you're supposed to drive your life
forward and that means you must start
looking ahead yeah you screwed up me too
the worst things that you've done
witnessed or survived they are your most
powerful teachers so stop making
yourself wrong about what happened and
unlocking packet understand it face
yourself in the mirror and learn the
lessons that are woven into every
mistake every regret you ever have and
every painful thing you've ever
experienced here's the profound Insight
I gain that I want you to hear you
aren't broken you're just blocked
forgive yourself for all the things you
did while you were just trying to
survive your mind collects mental lint
that's right that's all that doubt is
that's all that fear is that's all that
anxiety is that's all that worry is it's
all the people pleasing is
this is lint from life that is collected
in your brain and you know what lent
stands for something get your pencils
ready
you lose inspiration due to negative
thoughts
that's all that's happening you're not
broken you're just blocked the filter in
your mind is blocked just like a dryer
filter gets blocked by lint and you
can't think this stuff away you got to
take action
and the single most effective tool on
the planet hands down to wipe away the
lint in your mind to wipe away the doubt
to wipe away the fear to wipe away the
anxiety is the five second rule I'm dead
serious about this
when you feel
the fear rise up when you feel the
self-doubt start to block
when you feel the anxiety start to take
over when you feel like you're losing
the inspiration to move you're just
going to count backwards five four three
two one
I know it sounds dumb
but trust me on this one counting
backwards five four three two one wipes
the lint off the filter in your brain
that lint that makes you lose your
inspiration to act due to negative
thoughts
and once you get to one it's clear
so your confidence and your courage can
flow right through you this one is like
really important you need to do the work
okay you got to do the work because it's
only through your actions that you will
accomplish what you want let's say uh
that you've always wanted to climb a
particular Mountain okay there's a
mountain called Haystack it's not even
that tall so I should probably pick a
bigger one but let's just call it
Haystack Mountain you've always wanted
to climb Haystack Mountain you pull up
to Haystack Mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know National Forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my God
that's a really far way away you know I
don't really know how I feel about doing
this anymore because that looks like
it's going to take a really long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go I don't think I want to
do this because I don't think I feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamed of
climbing you've now come up with an
excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it you pull the rip cord you're out
of there in order to have what you want
in life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down and look
at the first step in front of you and
then you must take the action and start
walking toward what you want and it'll
be a hell of a lot easier for you to do
that if you have also been putting in
the time every day consistently to not
only see yourself walking up that trail
step by step but that you have felt
yourself pushing through the resistance
the fear the obstacles the excuses that
are stopping you now and feel proud in
every fiber of your being as you push
through those obstacles and see yourself
and feel yourself doing the work that's
how you manifest properly and if you do
that before you pull into the National
Park parking lot if you look up up at
that mountain and you see clouds and it
starts raining it won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment and your mind body and spirit and
you my friend will start walking up that
trail
and you're going to be proud that's how
you use manifesting to get what you want
that's how you leverage all the science
and research to train and prepare your
mind body and spirit to help you get
what you want and that's how you hack
the motivation and inspiration that you
need to take the actions that get you
everything that you want and deserve in
life the Dallas Uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into countless
Ubers and some small percentage of them
know who I am and then of course they
start asking questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back and how much pain people
feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet they're spending all of their
time and energy arguing against what
they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning uh actor and creating
opportunities for other black and Latino
men to do the same in acting and I'm
like freaking fantastic what the [ __ ]
are you doing in Dallas right yeah the
guy's 25 and so I I go you know the game
is in New York and L.A I mean sure you
can act you can write stuff you can be
here in Dallas but why are you not in La
why are you not in New York and he's
like you're right you're right you're
right I need to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves you must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank are you crossing the Finish
Line are you launching that business are
you having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
got to pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are prepared their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you you know when
you're about to meet a friend somebody
you really like at a cafe
I'm gonna go have a cup of tea
what do you feel right before you walk
in the door
excitement enthusiasm energy Joy uh
positive nervousness like that that kind
of like uh butterflies even in a
positive sense yeah so at this moment I
was 51 years old
in 51 years of being alive I don't ever
remember feeling
that feeling about seeing myself wow for
the first time in my life I had this
sensation
that I was excited to see the human
being Mel Robbins
now I've been excited to see an outfit
or excited to see a haircut
I have never been excited to see the
person
um and so I round the corner and this
sense of how profound this is is hitting
me and I'm standing there brushing my
teeth and I realize something really
wild
there are always two of you in the
bathroom together
there's you
and there is a human being in the mirror
a person who needs you
a person who has been waiting for you to
wake up and realize they are there and
they need you to see them and to hear
them and to love them and to support
them
and so what's interesting because you
brought up morning routines right is
that we all talk about the importance of
setting our day up because it's how it
ends up we talk about gratitude and
meditation and we know the extraordinary
benefits of it
but I don't think anybody has truly
Amplified the fact that there is this
dirty habit that we all have every
single morning that is a part of your
morning routine unless you have weeded
this out and it is a habit of either
ignoring yourself
or beating the heck out of yourself
every single morning in the mirror I
mean 91 percent of women don't like how
they look fifty percent of us can't even
look at ourselves in the mirror one of
the things that I think you should
always come back to First is take a look
at how you set your day up because how
you set it up is how it ends up how do I
set my day up so that I'm practicing
what I call Simple discipline simple
discipline is nothing more than making
and keeping simple promises to yourself
repeating it every day the way that you
start to change the big things is you
change the Small Things make tiny teeny
teeny promises to yourself and then keep
them so how do you build simple
discipline here are some core skills
that I do every morning that have helped
me number one I do not sleep with the
phone number two when the alarm goes off
on my phone it's not near me so I have
to get my ass out of bed I get up and I
make my bed I get moving
I get my exercise clothes on I move my
body and then Journal I take 10 minutes
to myself to plan my day when I do that
my day is incredible I believe that how
you start your day dictates how the day
goes you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you
you need to cuss
for yourself in the morning what are the
five senses what's the first thing that
you see when you wake up for me it's a
painting that I manifested out of thin
air it reminds me that what you put your
mind to and what you work toward it will
become a reality I always light incense
because it makes my senses and my nose
come alive I'm super mindful over what I
taste first thing in the morning my
grandma always had vinegar in the
morning with honey and hot water I
picked the one thing that matters to me
today you're a big proponent of the
growth mindset you guys talk about it
all the time on the show right so
researchers wanted to know what is the
most empowering way to motivate kids
through a really big challenge okay they
divide the kids into three groups this
takes the marshmallow test to a whole
nother level you got one group of kids
that are doing a challenging task and
they're getting the fixed mindset praise
which we all know does not work oh Tom
you're so smart oh Tom I love your
glasses that's going to help you out mom
you got a great smile oh Tom you know I
I just love so much about you I know you
can do this so that's one group the
second group gets the growth mindset
kind of phrase Tom you are such a hard
worker Tom your perseverance is
unbelievable Tom you just keep going
that does better obviously than telling
you that you're smart because it makes
you motivated to work hard the third
group
they just got a simple high five the
researchers didn't even say anything to
the kids they just walked up gave them a
high five the group of kids that got a
simple high five
outperformed outworked through all of
the challenges all of the other forms of
Praise why because a high five is
something deeper than praise it fulfills
your most fundamental needs as a human
being when somebody high fives you you
feel seen
you feel heard
and you feel like somebody has
acknowledged
you for the unique person that you are
and one of the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that only
happens like once in my lifetime those
numbers are going to line up like that
today is a really cool date let's go do
something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going to happen for me I want my
mind to reprogram itself and see other
people's businesses and see other people
getting healthy and see other people in
relationships and I want my mind to say
yeah if they can do it I can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can I if that person can find
somebody unhinged so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the Bulls from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there I completely forgotten
about the audiobook because I was so
focused on this New York Times things
and by the way here's another thing
you can't make the New York Times list
if you're a self-published author
something I didn't even know when I
started so
here I thought I'd fail didn't achieve
my dream the whole thing
I get this email
your monthly report is ready and I'm
like monthly report what are they
talking about I click on that report I
open it up I am literally like oh my God
audio books
audiobooks who new audiobooks were a
thing here's what happened
the entire time that I kept going
something amazing was happening Lisa
they were going to the hardcover but it
wasn't available they bought the only
thing that was available the audiobook
the five second rule became the number
one audiobook of the Year Lisa
it to this day is the most successful
self-published audiobook in the history
of audible
and it created a brand new partnership
that I have with audible something by
the way that I never would have had
happen
had my hardcover
campaign be successful
and here's the other thing I have never
achieved my goal of being a New York
Times Society author and I might never
achieve it I've never made a traditional
bestseller list
and it proves something that I believe
very deeply and that is that your dreams
and the things that you put on your
vision board have a very important
purpose
they pull you through your fears
they inspire you to take action
but they are not necessarily meant to be
achieved I believe when you pursue your
dreams
and you keep going and you keep telling
yourself that if I work hard something
amazing is going to happen you'll
achieve something better
something that you don't even know or
can even think about right now because
it's not even on your radar screen those
dreams are dots on the map of your life
that pull you in a direction you're
meant to go
but you might never end up there because
you're meant to end up somewhere else I
actually have an incredible quote of
yours about dreams you say when it comes
to your dreams you have two choices
pursue them or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it there are four
techniques that I use whenever I'm going
to have a difficult conversation that
help me stay focused on what I need to
talk about instead of getting hijacked
by my emotions number one I always start
the conversation by acknowledging my
responsibility in the mess that we have
to talk about whether it's the fact that
I've avoided dealing with this sooner or
whether there's something that I've done
that's contributed to the situation I
acknowledge it right up front and one of
the reasons why that's so important is
because by accepting some responsibility
you're defusing the other person's
emotion you're also honoring them a
little bit and it sets a much more Level
Playing Field for when you get into the
difficult things that you need to talk
about it's also going to put the person
that you're speaking to a little at ease
so they're going to be able to listen
number two you want to have a goal never
go into a difficult conversation without
an outcome defined before you go into it
the reason why the outcome is so
important is because this conversation
is going to be a roller coaster the
person that you're talking to might get
upset you yourself might feel emotional
at some point whether you're angry or
you're triggered or you get sad and so
when you ride the roller coaster of
emotion the thing that is going to
stabilize your thoughts is the outcome
that you're causing you're having this
conversation because you're committed to
making the relationship better you're
having this conversation because this
isn't working and so we need to end it
powerfully you're having this
conversation because you want to give
somebody some feedback that's not so fun
to tell them but you're giving it to
them because you're committed to their
success okay so that goal you feel
yourself getting emotional you come back
to it you come back to it you come back
to it third thing you're going to do a
lot in this conversation you're going to
listen and you're going to validate
so you're going to say what you need to
say and then the other person is going
to react and instead of arguing or
debating I want you to listen and I want
you to validate what the person is
saying may sound counter-intuitive but
honestly one of the most powerful things
you can do in any conversation whether
you're fighting with your kids over
curfew or you're arguing with somebody
at work over workloads whatever it may
be is hear where the person's at
the moment you say wow
that must be really tough what you're
dealing with or oh I totally get why you
now were avoiding me
if I felt the way that you felt I'd
probably do the same thing
the second you validate somebody they
immediately stop defending themselves
it's unbelievable actually
unbelievable you've got to try it
validate validate validate it is the
most powerful thing and then once of
course they feel validated that you've
heard them now they can listen
and that's when you come back to the
final thing which is you're going to
restate always the outcome keep coming
back to it keep coming back to it and
yeah it's not going to be fun
it's not going to be easy you're going
to have all kinds of emotions come up
because you've been avoiding this
conversation but I'm telling you right
now
if you find the confidence and the
courage to go and to start this thing
acknowledge your responsibility have an
outcome in mind validate the other
person validate validate validate and
keep talking until you hit that outcome
you're going to be really really amazed
at how much easier these things become
and if you want to make it even easier
on yourself rehearse it with another
friend first somebody that's not
involved in the situation because again
difficult conversations comes down to
one important thing
the ability for you to separate your
emotion about doing it from the things
you actually need to talk about and the
outcome that you want to cause if you
can't stand in front of the mirror and
raise your hand and high-five yourself
just because you got your ass out of bed
and you're breathing
you will never get what you want in life
ever there is something in the
resistance to it and if you unpack the
resistance you will find the reason why
you don't have what you want you either
think you're not worthy of it or you
think that it's kind of stupid or you
have been brought up to believe that for
women in particular you're going to be
[ __ ] or selfish or not likable if
you're celebrating yourself there is
something in the resistance to you
simply
cheering for yourself one of the biggest
objections that people had to standing
in front of the mirror take a moment
look at yourself and then raise your
hand
as people said over and over and over
again
I haven't done anything
Worthy
of high-fiving
high-fiving feels like a celebration
I don't have the number on the scale
that I want I don't like my bank account
I don't enjoy what I do for a living
I've made a load of mistakes I'm
struggling with trauma I don't have
anything to celebrate
and what I realized is
people are making a fundamental mistake
you are withholding the very support
empowerment and celebration that you
need to change and to do the hard work
and to face the things that you're
scared of
and that's why
you're not changing when I think back
three years ago where I was like saw one
of your videos or Gary's videos or
somebody I'm like oh I just need to
start filming the book lines at these
and it was uh it was a moment it was
this little amount of wisdom inside of
me that I listened to and I am telling
you that is the power you got to tune
out the noise and you got to learn how
to make what I call a quiet decision
yeah a quiet decision where you
shh and you hear what your heart is is
urging you to do let's start with a
metaphor
I want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters
some chapters are boring and a grind to
get through and others are exciting and
you hope they never end and right now
you're in a chapter
[Music]
maybe this chapter of your life is a
grind it's overwhelming and unsatisfying
and you feel stuck reading it over and
over again
maybe you want to start a new chapter
but you don't know what the next chapter
is about and so you keep re-reading the
one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life
you don't have to know where this next
chapter is going
you just have to start writing it
I want you to Envision a blank page
what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself I don't
want you to try to figure out what job
or business you should write on that
page what belongs on that page are the
dreams that you have for yourself and
your life
and all that's required to start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school yes you
should try to launch that business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate or it's a 20-year
career that you're just burnt out on or
maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this is the moment to write your next
chapter
you're not too late
you're right on time
all you need is a blank page and a pen
do tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can move your body because
negativity gets stored here and moving
your body we know based on the research
simply moving your body for 10 or 20
minutes a day will release chemicals in
your mind that help you boost your mood
the second thing that will boost your
mood is I want you to make a tiny
promise to yourself every day just one
thing that makes you feel more positive
is it getting up on time
is it eating something healthy is it
only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail I want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise I want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is have a
zero tolerance policy for your own
negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world I woke up this morning I
looked in the mirror
I looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here and I started to go negative I
started to feel dreary and I went Mel
cut this [ __ ] out you gotta fight to
stay positive gal because we are in this
for another couple months and do not
succumb to despair do not start thinking
native stuff when you have negativity
internally you gotta have a zero
tolerance policy for that it's one thing
to feel what you need to feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second that negative five
four three two one
not listening to it no I am redirecting
my thoughts that's right I am looking
for the things I can control I am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that I can control right now
today
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent interview with Mel Robbins one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I hope
your business goes bankrupt Evan Evan
you're a terrible person I spent the
first 40 some years of my life trying to
be somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way